welcome back well we've heard from the
politicians now it's time to hear from
the voice of business I carry on
Fairburn the head of the CBI and joins
us now thank you very much for being
with us so well you were last on the
show in November so do you feel more
confident or less confident about brexit
now
oh well Sophie I think we really are in
the emergency zone of brexit now so I
think last November we have the
possibility of a deal on the table and
that has now that feels that has receded
we don't have a deal on the table
firms are having to plan in the here and
now for a No Deal brexit with all of the
pain that that will bring we know that
businesses are leaving the country we
know that businesses are making plans
that will damage communities across the
country and just this week we had a new
chapter in the unfolding nightmare which
is the prospect that the trade deals
that the the UK businesses enjoy through
the European Union will not be ready in
time for leaving so South Korea in
particular a real concern for businesses
so it really is the emergency zone on
those trade deals your deputy attended a
meeting with Olympics about the
possibility of the existing trade deals
that we enjoy as being part of the EU
being rolled over what I mean what is
the position as far as you understand
well I think ministers and officials
have been working very hard so it's not
for ones of trying
but it's genuinely hard because partner
countries who we've enjoyed free trade
deals with now for a number of years
under the EU are actually saying what we
want to see what your relationship is
first Japan is saying that for example
South Korea one of our main trading
partners they want to reopen terms so
the prospect is that the day after
brexit those deals will disappear and
what does that mean good jobs for the
court what does it mean for normal
people well I think that the the really
important thing about why what business
says matters is that this is how brexit
would be felt in communities across the
country it will be the decisions that
businesses take about jobs and
investment and they will reduce them so
you have fewer potential to potential to
trade globally that will mean less
investment in the future and that will
mean fewer jobs in the future we've seen
Sony move its headquarters I'm talking
to businesses that are planning for
price increases
for job reductions after a no job brexit
this is very very real now now you were
saying about when we last week there was
at least the prospect of a deal and you
feel that that is now receding what do
you think and the chances of a No Deal
well they feel as though they have gone
up because the possibility of the Prime
Minister's deal passing feels as that
has receded and I think what business is
saying is compromise find that middle
ground and at the moment it feels like
the parliamentary process is in logjam
no way can be found through so that
prospect of No Deal feels much higher
but what I think businesses everyone I
speak to is saying get round the table
find that compromise and get that deal
so we can take I mean hope the
compromise be the Jeremy Corbyn proposal
the permanent customs union well there
are number of things when that letter
was published I think businesses will
have looked at that and thought yep
there is no number of things here that
could work for business we at the CBI
have said that actually a customs union
of some sort would be a good thing for
most businesses but it's not the only
solution so with that on the table now
from from from labor we would really
urge politicians and leaders from all
parties to get run that around the table
and find a solution on that there isn't
just one model that won't work for
business that would work but there are
others so you basically take any deal is
better than no deal is that what you're
saying the things that matter for
business are frictionless trade access
for our services and access to people
and talent any deal that delivers along
those lines will work for business the
issue now is time and we are heading
towards that cliff edge so we need that
deal so you think you're talking about
the issue it's time less than 50 days to
go until brexit so what our business is
doing right now well I think there's
been real acceleration in the planning
so we have got stockpiling we know that
warehousing capacity has run out there
is they are preparing for disruption at
borders but I think that the bigger
thing that's going on is that there is
also a recalibration if you like of what
UK is like as a place to invest we have
been a fantastic country to invest in
for many years a gateway to Europe we
have great timezone great universities
and yet um investors are looking at the
UK and asking questions about what we
like for the long term hence the
decision by Nissan BRICS it wasn't the
only factor but it was one
so you having conversations with this
long-term telling you that that they
were not going to invest or that they
are going to move us well absolutely so
these plans are on the stocks and they
are still traveling in hope around a
deal so some have taken action but
others are waiting many small businesses
have not been able to take action at all
so they will hit be hit by the shock but
the point is that we we have this
opportunity now to get a deal on the
table pass it and move on
and return the UK to being its it the
great place to invest that it has been
but this isn't this is real danger time
now it's interesting hearing you talk do
you when you look at what's happening in
Westminster what do you feel towards
politicians I think that there is just
an astonishment that businesses feel
that can turn into anger actually
because we have a political process here
that is not delivering a solution for
our country so here we are ten years on
from the financial crash we have we we
had a risk here we're going to recreate
some of the conditions around the
financial crash the Bank of England
today has a forecast which puts growth
at the lowest it has been in the last
ten years why would we voluntarily do
that to ourselves as a country we know
that the financial crash harms the
youngest in our population most young
people into the workplace why would we
do that again and I think there there is
a sense that this is almost negligence
on behalf of our political institutions
or political leaders in not delivering a
solution to this we have 47 days left
that solution needs to be found if it
breaks it that that's the problem
or the way that it's been handled I
think brexit the decision that was taken
52 48 was always going to be challenging
however here we are 47 days to go again
that number and we actually are not only
further on if you're a business in terms
of having clarity about what the trading
environment will be when we leave and
that that has the process has not
delivered any clarity at all so we need
that to happen very fast now okay clear
message thank you very much being
program